imaginer des professeurs en
mathématiques et en technologie qui
aurait un objectif commun qui puisse
venir ici avec deux classes et
travailler sur un projet sur deux heures
ce lieu c'est la fabrique un projet
imaginé par des équipes pédagogiques du
collège les grands champs à Poissy avec
cet espace l'établissement souhaite
innover dans l'apprentissage des élèves
encore au stade de l'idée les équipes
participent au concertation pour l'école
ils espèrent recevoir un financement
pour que ce tiers-lieux puisse exister
tout le monde aura une participation
dans ce projet les parents d'élèves et
les élèves seront associés mais on est
une équipe on va dire d'une petite
dizaine très mobilisée pour le
construire à partir des retours de tous
il faudra que je compile avec mon équipe
tout ce qui a été exprimé pour pouvoir
rendre au 15 janvier une copie claire
sur ce que ce tiers-lieux devrait être
cette journée constitue la première
concertation du collège les grands
champs trois autres phases de dialogues
sont prévus pour mûrir le projet le but
de concertation c'est de parler de
parler ensemble non pas de faire des
grands débats sur l'école mais de parler
de son école
son école et de pouvoir discerner des
lignes sur des projets qui sont très
concrets sur ce qui peut amener des
projets intéressants
concordants entre tous et que nous
pourrions financer dans le cadre d'un
fond d'innovation pédagogique le
président de la République a souhaité
mettre en place à l'échelle de
l'académie de Versailles plus de 800
établissements participent à ce type de
concertation
l'objectif recevoir un financement du
fond d'innovation pédagogique doté de
500 millions d'euros